Well,
I happened to be a fan of democracy.
I think it has flaws,
but there was just no other better
system for one simple reason,
and that is you can often get a bit
inefficient dictator.
A lot of people think that Lee Kuan Yew
in Singapore was such a person.
He was not corrupt.
He actually alleviated a lot of the
ethnic conflict.
But here's the problem.
You could never ensure that the dictator
will stay beneficence,
and the better thing about democracy is
that eventually you can vote them out.
If you don't like the policies.
If you don't like the leaders,
you can vote them out.
So on balance,
I think that democracy is the best
system.
What I think is wrong is that America
treats democracy like a panacea.
We romanticize it.
We think somehow that,
oh,
there's all this civil war and tribalism
and sectarian warfare there.
Let's just have some elections.
What they don't realize is that in very
divided countries,
ethnically divided,
tribally divided democracy can sometimes
capitalize group conflict rather than
softening it.
A lot of people have puzzled over how so
many blue collar and working class
Americans could possibly have voted for
a billionaire born to wealth born in
Manhattan,
but it's actually not a puzzle at all.
What a lot of working class Americans
resent is the idea that there's a rigged
system,
that there are these people,
arrogant people controlling the leavers
of power from afar,
somewhere in DC and on Wall Street and
Silicon Valley.
If you look at the surveys,
Pew Foundation Studies,
you find that most Americans,
including working class Americans
actually love capitalism.
They don't want socialism.
They still want a system where you could
work hard,
you can strike it rich,
and they want it to be fine to be rich.
Study show that many working class
Americans actually resent the
professional elites bore the very
polished,
well-educated snobby professors and
journalists and pundits speaking on TV
and that they don't actually dislike the
Kardashians so much,
or the billionaires that are jet setting
around.
That's why shows like the apprentice are
so popular.
The occupy movement in many important
things highlighting the urgency of
inequality in this country,
but one problem with the occupy movement
is that it was a movement that purported
to want to help the poor that didn't
actually include any members of the
poor.
It was overwhelmingly an extremely
privileged movement,
not necessarily wealthy,
but highly educated and largely from
cosmopolitan urban areas,
and if you look at the interviews of
people from other parts of the country
working class people,
blue collar people,
it's not just that they didn't
participate in these activist anti
quality movements.
They actually were very suspicious of
them and even a little scornful.
The interviews have people saying,
don't these people have jobs?
Don't they have to work?
I'm working three jobs just to put food
on the table.
How can they be marching and protesting
all the time?
Now,
that's a little unfair because a lot of
these activists movements have done
tremendous good,
but it is also true that it is a
privilege to have the time to take off
work and to do these things.
So there's a real schism in group
identities.
A lot of America's elites,
while they were campaigning for Bernie
or hillary,
didn't really connect with so many of
the lower income Americans because in
part they had a snobby view towards
them,
but the point is that a lot of America's
political elites,
the establishment elites,
just really didn't bother to get to
understand the people that supposedly
they were trying to help.
It's amazing to contrast the occupied
movement with the Prosperity Gospel.
The irony is just glaring so occupy was
a movement championing supposedly the
underclasses,
but largely driven by elites.
The Prosperity Gospel is a hugely
popular movement in America.
What are the most powerful religious
movements in the United States that is
very largely populated by disadvantaged
Americans,
including our most disadvantaged
minorities?
African Americans and Hispanic Americans
are flocking to the Prosperity Gospel.
What is their creed that God blesses the
wealthy,
that being rich is divine,
and that if you pray for wealth hard
enough,
God will give it to you.
And this contrast just shows the tribal
chasm between America's haves and have
nots.
You have people purporting to want to
help the other side and yet actually
scorning the very movements that those
people actually belong to.
We have a strange relationship with
celebrity culture in America,
and in some ways you could see the
victory of Donald Trump as Donald Trump
tapping into this obsession with
celebrities.
It's almost like he's created a kind of
billionaire populism where he's tapping
into this desire for a lot of working
class people to rise in a system where
they can no longer rise,
where there's so much inequality that
they can't just make it with hard work
and they romanticize that.
They think,
you know what?
If I go on American idol or the voice or
shark tank,
maybe I can hit it big and they actually
glorify all the desperate housewives or
the Kardashians or the celebrity
musicians and actresses.
These are beloved figures.
They're not hated it all.
It's like the royal family in England.
The desire for the American dream is so
powerful that people will cling to it
even when they have no chance.
Even when the American dream turned
their backs on,
people mocks them.
A lot of Americans would sooner turn on
immigrants,
outsiders even reason itself.
Then turn on the American dream.
I'm a lot of people think,
why is this happening now?
You know,
what,
what's going on with our society?
Well,
it's always been there.
A lot of these issues have always been
there.
There's always been a,
these male bosses that have done these
terrible things.
So it's not like it's all happening now.
It's just that finally certain groups
voices are allowed to be heard.
It the same with,
um,
a lot of diversity issues.
You know,
people will say,
why now are there so many minorities
complaining on campuses or in this
organization,
it used to be so smooth.
Things used to work so well.
Well that's because so many voices used
to be suppressed.
So in a way I think it's healthy.
What's often experienced as turbulence
and chaos,
oh my gosh,
everything's going haywire is actually a
healthy,
a rising of certain voices that
historically have not been allowed to
speak.
And there are lots of different groups.
It's a long all kinds of different
lines,
gender,
race,
ethnicity.
Because I mean,
it's,
it's everything.